So we can install multiple instances
of the engine next application now.
But can we run them?
Let's use the Docker Run command
to run the first instance
of the engine next container.
Now we can use the Docker PS command
to check that it's up and running.
I could run another.
It doesn't even have to
be the same version.
Notice this time, since we didn't have
the image array on our system for
version 1.9.3 of nginx,
the docker run command pulls
the image in the background first.
Sometimes when I'm home alone,
I'll sit in front of my computer and
just start up hundreds of instances.
Just because I can.
Let's run one more.
I'll stick to three today.
We can see that we have all three
instances running using the P.S.
command from earlier.
You can see from the output that we have
three nginx master processes running.
Docket makes this so easy.
We don't have to touch nsscripts,
setup ports, or any of that stuff to run
multiple instances, or even different
versions, at the same time.